Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
dann abonniert uns,
lasst uns einen Daumen nach oben.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
dann abonniert uns,
lasst uns einen Daumen nach oben.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
dann abonniert uns,
lasst uns einen Daumen nach oben.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
OMEGALOOL
Moin Leute!
Ich muss euch mal was erzählen.
Eigentlich sehr merkwürdig.
Aber...
Ich hatte heute überhaupt nicht vorzustreben,
ne?
Aber ich hab auf die Uhr geguckt
und hab festgestellt,
komm mal da,
schon 20 Uhr
und irgendwie ist der Tag nicht
komplett ohne eine Runde
Twitch-Stream so.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was los ist, ja.
Das ist ja fast schon
regelmäßige,
regelmäßiger Stream-Content.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was los ist.
Was ist denn denn Labor Day?
Bestimmt irgendso, irgendso
Kona-Feiertag.
Der Kupfer-Mann.
Also, da
Kupfer-Mann.
Abonniert Twitch Prime
Stufe, was haben wir denn?
Was heißt Stufe? Stufe 1.
Aber 6 Monate am Stück, sehr nice.
Das ist schon einen...
Das ist ja nicht mehr ein normaler Subscriber,
das ist ja schon wirklich...
Ach, das ist Tag der Arbeit.
Ah, excellent.
Da hätte man selbst drauf kommen können.
Der ist ja... Der ist ja...
Ist das nicht Tag der Arbeit irgendwann?
Ist das nicht am 1. Mai?
Das müsste doch...
Das müsste doch irgendwann...
Das müsste doch jetzt
irgendwann sein, oder?
1. Mai.
Oder ist Feiertag, oder?
Was ist denn das?
Am Freitag!
Am Freitag ist Feiertag!
Das muss mir auch aber einer sagen.
Das heißt, die Woche ist fast schon wieder um.
Easy clap.
Das habe ich so überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Ohne Chap wäre es erst mal auf die Arbeit gegangen.
Na ja, gehen eh nicht.
Es ist eh noch da, im Homeoffice.
Ach.
360 Noscope.
Ja, aber nur weil du es bist.
Moment, wo habe ich es? Wo habe ich es?
Wo ist mein 360 Noscope?
Hier.
Das wäre mir gar nicht aufgefallen,
dass das am Freitag ja frei ist.
Wahnsinn.
Das ist ja sehr nice.
Das heißt im Endeffekt auch,
ich muss nur noch Donnerstag arbeiten.
Weil dreimal dürft ihr raten,
was ich morgen mal wieder habe.
Morgen habe ich schon wieder eine
Microsoft Azure-Schulung.
Klar online,
alles online.
Ich sehe mein Fenster nicht,
wo ich resizen kann.
Wo ist mein Fenster zum Resizen hier?
Oh.
Leute, gleich ist er weg.
Gleich ist er weg.
Er verschwindet.
Da ist er wieder.
So.
Kramme mal zu.
Der Patrick muss noch kurz
auf Arbeit gehen, easy. Mach mal.
Denk an die Atemschutzmaske.
Ähm.
Die Atemschutzmaske.
Aber wobei es geht.
Oh, ich muss ja noch was nachgucken.
Windows stellt ja gerne
die Soundsettings um.
Oh, heute hat es nur zwei Stück
hochgestellt. Sehr gut.
Das ist bei Teams nicht so ganz klar.
Aber Chet, es ist gut, dass ihr mir das gesagt habt.
Sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich morgen,
nicht morgen, am Freitag,
irgendeine Homeoffice-Beginten-Mail geschrieben
und hätte dann festgestellt, oh,
ähm, ist ja heute
gar nichts. Oder wahrscheinlich hätte ich
es gar nicht gemerkt. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich mich
bloß gewundert, es ist aber heute wenig los.
Du kannst Applikationen die Rechte nehmen, das umzustellen.
Echt, das geht?
Jetzt
kommen hier die Big-Brain-Plays.
Ja.
Oh, die Hacks, Leute. Leak!
Die Wallhacks wurden geleakt. Jetzt habe ich
mich selbst überführt.
Ne, du musst in die
alten Einstellungen gehen.
Okay.
Äh, ich muss vorher mal meine VM anmachen,
dann übersehe ich die ganzen
Questions wieder.
Ne, du musst in die alten
... Du musst eine Mail schreiben,
wenn du mit Homeoffice anfängst.
Ja, wir haben das so geregelt.
Was ist wir haben das so geregelt? Das ist so, das ist
bei uns so geregelt. Es ist nicht so, als hätte ich da jetzt
irgendwie großartigen Einfluss darauf gehabt,
wie das geregelt wird.
Also bei uns ist das so geregelt,
dass jeder schreibt, wenn er anfängt und aufhört.
Und, ähm,
das ist dann auch mit Zider-Fasern
einfacher.
Da musst du nichts Großartiges mehr machen.
Einfach startet, endet,
fertig.
Sagen wir insofern ganz gut, dann ruft dich auch keiner mehr an.
Ah.
Das muss ich ausschalten.
Redeem your points, okay.
Was kann man mit den Microsoft-Points
machen?
Das kann man mit dem Microsoft-Points
machen.
eigentlich machen, also mit
den Points hier,
mit denen da.
Was macht man mit den Points
eigentlich?
Ach, leg mich Microsoft
kein Bock.
Da kannst du die Xbox Live oder andere Gutscheine
eintauschen. Okay.
Aber dafür muss ich,
aber dafür muss ich Bing benutzen.
Ich will keinen Bing benutzen.
Bing.
Also ich muss ja sagen,
was ich in letzter Zeit ziemlich oft
verwende, ist das hier.
Das ist eigentlich neben Google so meine Hauptsuchmaschine
mittlerweile.
Ich finde die echt nicht schlecht.
Und gerade wenn Google
irgendwelche, gerade wenn du irgendwelche Sourcecode-Sachen
suchst,
Doctor Go ist
das Bing.
Das Bing unter der Haube ist mir eigentlich okay.
Das soll mir recht sein.
Zumindest habe ich
den Eindruck, dass ich dort,
ich habe es mit Bing noch gar nicht ausprobiert,
ehrlich gesagt.
Dass gerade
wenn man Sourcecode-Sachen sucht,
dass man da manchmal
doch eine Ecke besser dran ist,
als über Google.
Jetzt benutzt du
Ecosia. Was ist denn Ecosia?
Ach, das sind die.
Von denen habe ich schon was gehört, aber ich habe das noch nie benutzt.
Was kann die denn?
Search the web to plant trees.
Aha, yes, excellent.
Okay.
Wenn ich suche, wenn Bäume,
okay, dann suchen wir mal nach.
Oh, Max FPX
gibt es nicht.
Habe ich jetzt
Bäume gepflanzt?
Einen Mammutbaum.
Warum muss es ausgerechnet ein Mammutbaum sein?
Tut es nicht irgendwie so eine Tanne oder so auch?
Na gut, also wenn das im Endeffekt
auch nur rebrandetes Bing ist,
da kann man es verwenden.
Ich bin ja bei solchen Sachen
immer ein bisschen kritisch,
weil ich frage mich dann immer so,
also Sachen, die so
auf den ersten Blick so diesen grünen
Anstrich haben, ich bin immer skeptisch,
ob der auch wirklich so ist. Hat sich das jemand schon
mal im Detail angeguckt?
Ob da auch was dahinter
ist?
Weil es gibt ja viele
Sachen, die sich
gerne einen grünen Anstrich verleihen.
Was ich ganz grotesk
immer finde, ist, wenn ich Werbung auf
Twitter bekomme,
von irgendwelchen
Ölkonzernen oder so,
die dann erzählen, wir sind seit Jahrzehnten
schon führend im Bereich von erneuerbaren
Energien und grünem ist,
irgendwie grünem Kraftstoff und sonst was.
Und ich meine, ja, ist klar.
Das Einzige, was ihr seid, ist
irgendwelche Marketingschwätzer, denen jetzt
der Arsch so ein bisschen auf Grundeis geht,
dass die Leute keinen Bock mehr auf euch haben
oder euch nicht brauchen. Ich frage mich ja eh,
was die in Saudi
Arabien demnächst machen, wenn der
Ölpreis weiter so scheiße ist.
Oder auch die Norweger.
Norweger verdienen ja auch viel mit dem Öl.
Habt ihr gesehen,
dass der Ölpreis letztens unter Wasser war?
Oder sogar Minus hatte?
Also kurz gucken,
ob ich keine Subs übersehen habe.
Der Carlson Achtmonat,
Huge Sub Hype, Wahnsinns, Wahnsinns IQ,
der platzt gleich der Kopf.
Aber vor allem
nur noch den Kupfermann, den hatten wir aber schon.
Mitnein Mannheimer,
Moin.
Ähm
Ja, habt ihr das jetzt?
Also der ist übelst...der ist...
Was denn da...ich hab keinen...
Ich kenn mich damit nicht wirklich aus.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Okay, es ist anscheinend
wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen jetzt.
Aber das war aber wirklich kurz so...
RIP
Ja, ich frag mich, was machen die jetzt
in Saudi-Arabien die Leute?
Wann müssen die dann etwa was arbeiten gehen
oder so, wenn der Ölpreis fällt?
Das ist ja nicht auszudenken.
Nicky 30, 5 Monate,
Dankeschön, Huge Sub.
Das ist, weil die zahlen immer zu einem festen Termin.
Achso, also die haben quasi im Vorfeld
schon
zu einem festen Preis gekauft.
Oder wie?
Und dann mussten sie das irgendwann einlösen.
Auf Banggood sind die K95 Masken.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was die Masken kosten.
Wie heißt die Dinger?
Maske de protection
oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Maske de...
Wie spricht man das auch?
Okay, Moment, Aussprache Französisch.
Moment, Moment.
Aussprache
French.
Aussprache French.
WTF.
Mehr, mehr Wörter...
Ach du...
Aussprache Französisch.
Mehr Kombinationen von nicht Französisch
gegen die Aussprache.
German into French.
Auf hier, auf hier, Französische Aussprache.
Nein.
Ja.
Was?
Moment, Moment.
Mas...
Ach du, ich kann kein Französisch reden.
Ich krieg's nicht hin.
Maske de protection.
Okay, Maske de protection.
Alles klar. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Also falls ihr euch demnächst mal nach Frankreich verirrt,
könnt ihr auch Maske de protection
kaufen.
Du kannst nicht mal Deutsch.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Aber man muss schon sagen, ich komme
mit meiner Mischung aus Deutsch
und Englisch im Gelaber eigentlich ganz gut
über die Runden.
Okay, was hat der Sebaro gemeint? Soll ich suchen
K... Was? K
95. Facemask.
Ach, das ist so eine normale.
Warum haben die Löcher drin?
Ah, da kann man
unterschiedliche Filter da vormachen.
Und was ist das dahinter? Ist das ein Chicken Wing?
Leute,
ist das ein Chicken Wing?
So ein, so ein,
so ein Kentucky Fried
Chicken Wing?
Hahahaha.
Das sieht aus wie ein
KFC
Chicken Wing.
Das sieht genauso aus.
Guck mal. Das ist ein Chicken Wing.
Seht ihr das?
Aber die Frage, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
selbst wenn es kein Chicken Wing ist,
was ist das?
Ich frage mich, das, es interessiert
mich.
Das interessiert mich mehr, was
das ist, als die Maske an sich.
Das ist Corona.
Ganz schön groß, oder?
Da wird man wenigstens Corona
mal sehen.
Leute, was ist
das?
Das ist
irgendein Stein.
irgendein Stein, Leute. Da hinten
ist er wieder. Das ist irgendein Stein.
Das sieht ja gefährlich aus.
Ist das ein Brötchen?
Was
ist das?
Was könnte Tempeh sein?
Was ist denn...
Oh, kann man das suchen?
Tempeh?
Was ist Tempeh?
Ist das ein Käse?
Chinesische Käse?
Oder was ist das?
Was ist das?
Das ist Brot.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Ich bin wirklich überfragt.
Die haben noch mehr so Dinge mit dem
gleichen Bild dahinter.
Der Erste, der mir schlüssig erklären kann,
das ist, gewinnt wieder eine Klo-Rolle.
Das sieht nicht nach dem Chicken-Wing aus.
Was ist das?
Ist das die Kopftuch-Variante,
die Vollverschleierungs-Variante
mit
der Atemschutzmaske?
Ach nee, eine Ski-Maske.
Ach, eine Ski-Maske ist das.
Oh, das sieht aber gefährlich aus.
Das könnte wirklich irgendein Gegner
aus Dark Souls sein, das stimmt schon.
Das ist so toll.
Die Chinesen, die haben nichts.
Man muss ja sagen,
so ein bisschen dieses Material
hat ein bisschen was von Frauen-
Unterwäsche hier vorne an der Maske.
Aber der Rest ist
echt fragwürdig.
Borpel, 6 Monate,
Dankeschön.
Ich muss mich mal einloggen,
dass ich keine
Subs übersehe.
Negi30,
Dankeschön, 5 Monate, ich weiß nicht,
wie das gehen wird, aber huge sub.
Lack? Oh nee, hör mal auf.
Kein Lack, please.
Vodafone. Nein,
nicht heute, nicht wieder. Kein Lack.
Geh weg.
Vodafone, geh weg.
Kein Lack.
Wir machen,
ich hab ne Idee.
Wir machen das einfach so.
Wenn es Lackt,
definieren wir einfach, dass es nicht Lackt.
Und dann Lackt es nie.
Okay, wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich auf diese
Atemschutzmasken gekommen?
Da wollte ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht hin.
Da
wollte ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht drauf.
Wenn es Lackt, genau.
Genau, das stimmt, wir sind auf die Atemschutzmasken
gekommen, weil da Sebaro, aber
Sebaro hat gesagt, wir sollen nach diesen
Masken suchen, also weiß da Sebaro doch
auch, was auf dem Bild zu erkennen
ist, oder?
Außer da, ob es nicht echt doch noch
ein Chickenwing ist.
Oh, die haben aber auch hier,
die haben aber auch hier die härtere
Variante hier. Aber die richtig
guten Masken, die haben,
was ist das denn?
Ah, die
richtig guten Masken, die gehen auch über die Augen.
Also bisschen creepy
ist das ja manchmal schon,
was die sich da ausdecken bei den Protokoller.
Oh, das ist
die hier, das ist schon mal besser.
Das geht zumindest auch über die Augen.
Enjoy,
great saving.
Jawoll, was gibt es denn zum Labor Day?
Zeig mal her, Flashdeals.
Was haben wir denn schönes zu bieten?
Eine 52 Euro VR
Brille.
Was ist denn das für ein Ding da vorne drauf?
Meine
Oma hätte jetzt gesagt,
das war so der Standardspruch, bei allem,
wenn die keine Ahnung hatte, was es ist,
hat die immer gesagt, das ist der Griff zum Fortschmeißen.
Ich gebe so letztlich schon
ein bisschen Pains Champ, der Spruch.
Aber ist mir jetzt gerade eingefallen.
Oh, da Tensa ist am Start.
3 Stufe 1 Abos.
An.
Ich pack mein Twitch-Chat gerade.
Ich hab nur noch gesehen, dass es Abos gibt.
3 Abos verschenkt.
Dankeschön. Und zwar
an, wir haben ja
Profi1y3
xthebeast10.
Auch das ist ja so richtig, xthebeast10.
Das ist so ein richtig cooler
Oldschool
Codename irgendwie. Und an
PClustig, der hat es verdient, der ist öfters am Start.
Den hab ich jetzt schon oft gesehen.
Huge, danke für die ganzen
spannenden Subs.
Ist eine Antenne. Das ist eine Antenne.
Ja, anscheinend, aber das
ganz schön ätzend, mit so einer Antenne rumzulaufen.
Ach, das ist für
Drone Racing, das ist gar keine 3D-Brille.
Ah,
das ist, ey, das ist
ist das die Windows XP-Wiese?
Nee, oder ist das nicht die Windows XP-Wiese?
Aber es sieht, es sieht der Windows XP-Wiese
doch schon verdächtig ähnlich.
Musste immer sagen, von der Farbgebung
und allem sieht das, ähm,
ich weiß, die Windows XP-Wiese hat einen Berg.
Aber es sieht von der Farbgebung und dem Himmel schon
alles, ähm, sehr nach
der Windows XP-Wiese
aus. Hier übrigens, letztens habt ihr gesehen,
äh, so sieht die
Windows XP-Wiese
heute aus, was man nicht alles
für einen Mist anguckt.
So sieht's heute aus.
Die Windows XP.
Der Windows XP-Wallpaper.
Die gibt's echt, tatsächlich, ja, die Windows XP-Wüste
gibt's echt.
RIP Windows XP-Wüste.
Macht, betreibt einer
von euch, äh, Drone Racing.
Hat eigentlich noch jemand eine Benachrichtigung, dass man keine Benachrichtigung
von Twitch bekommt.
Kann ich nix zu sagen.
Das ist nämlich ne Sache.
Irgendwie würd ich das ja gerne mal ausprobieren.
Irgendwie würd ich das echt gerne mal
ausprobieren.
Ihr würdet es gerne, das ist ziemlich toll.
Ich glaub, bei mir wird's nicht unbedingt an der
Kohle scheitern, die Sache ist bloß immer die.
Ich neige manchmal dazu,
mir sind Lust, eure Sachen zu kaufen,
sie zweimal zu verwenden und zu sagen, oh, ist ja geil
und dann die wieder anzufassen.
Ähm, aber
ich würd's echt gerne mal ausprobieren.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit
China-Graben, sondern mit was Gescheitem.
Aber irgendwie
würd ich's gerne mal ausprobieren.
Thron selber bauen ist nicht so teuer, aber ich glaube,
das ist erst mal ziemlich kompliziert,
oder?
Ich würd mir wahrscheinlich erst mal irgendwas halbwegs
gutes Fertiges kaufen, dass ich mal
ein bisschen ausprobieren kann.
Cool ist es schon, ich hab da ein paar Videos vorhin gesehen,
das ist ultra geil.
Da gehst du einfach an meinen, auf die Wiese,
setzt dir das Ding aus
und düst mal richtig rum.
Und da würde mich mal interessieren,
was das taugt, was das? Ist das ein Staubsauger?
Ist das ein Staubsauger?
Der Blitzwolf!
Keiner Name!
Blitzwolf-Straubensauger.
Das Ding kommt mir allerdings
nicht ins Haus, weil
es sieht aus, als hätt's ne Kamera.
Nee, oder? Das ist der Lade.
Was ist denn das?
Ist das ne Kamera,
oder ist das irgendwie der Ladeanschluss?
Was ist das?
Am Blitzwolf.
Das wichtigste ist ja eigentlich, gibt es
für den Blitzwolf Custom
Firmware. Sieht nach Ultraschall.
Nee, der Ultraschall ist ja oben drauf.
Ach nee, oben, im Moment, oben ist der Laser
drauf. Oben ist der Laser drauf,
dann ist das vielleicht wirklich ein Ultraschall-Sensor.
Das kann tatsächlich sein,
dann ist das vielleicht wirklich ein Ultraschall.
Das hier oben ist der Laser-Abstand-Mess-Sensor.
Staubsauger mit Alexa, klar.
Mein Staubsauger hätte
theoretisch auch Alexa, aber ich verwende ihn ja
mit Custom Firmware, also auch ohne Alexa,
und ich verwende ja sonst auch keine Alexa.
Oh, guck mal da!
Es gibt
Custom Firmware
für den Blitzwolf.
Ach nee.
Das ist aber kein Staubsauger.
Um nicht zu sagen, das ist sehr weit
entfernt von einem Staubsauger.
Blitzwolf.
Der Name ist schon geil irgendwie.
Ich muss meinen Staubsauger
übrigens neu flaschen letztens.
Der hat sich Factory resettet.
Hier, der da.
Der hat sich Factory, Factory
resettet.
Mein Staubsauger, übrigens das ist ein Web-Interface
von meinem Staubsauger. Nur mal so.
Wer es noch nicht gesehen hat,
da kann man richtig, richtig nice Dinger machen.
Man kann sich zum Beispiel
eine Karte anzeigen lassen, das ist aktuell nur das Wohnzimmer
drauf. Da sieht man die letzte Fahrt.
Dann kann
man hier einstellen, wie sehr er saugen
soll.
Wenn ich jetzt hier drauf
klicke,
Wohnort liegt auf einen Koss
Wenn ich jetzt hier drauf klicke, sagt er, sagt er irgendwie was, hallo hier bin ich, sagt er
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch, wenn man, wenn er irgendwo stecken geblieben ist, wobei er relativ wenig stecken bleibt
Ja, und jetzt kann man starten, stoppen und man kann ihm sogar Zonen definieren, wo er nicht hin darf und wo er hin darf
Zonen, wo er nicht hin darf und und
verschiedene Gebiete auf der Karte markieren, also wahrgenommen, ich hätte jetzt hier mal eine ganze Wohnung drin und jetzt nicht aktuell nur das Wohnzimmer
Dann könnte ich beispielsweise sagen, ok, hier vorne ist die Fenster, ist hier die Fensterbank
Wir können sagen, hier Zonen definieren unter der Fensterbank und
sagen wir mal, ich würde die Katze immer auf der Fensterbank füttern, dann könnte ich sagen, ok, jetzt unter der Fensterbank reinigen, da wird er hinfahren
Saug, Saug, Saug und wieder an die Dockingstation zurück
huge
Ja, und man kann, man kann das auch manuell steuern, das Ding, das ist quasi ein übergroßes Joystick-Ding hier
und dann kann man ihn mit der Hand rumsteuern
Das ist sehr nice und bei Einstellungen kann man Zeug, Zeug eingeben, Zeitsteuerung, dass er angeht
Karten restoren und so, weil die, also das ist jetzt auch ein Punkt, wo Custom-Firmware richtig gut, richtig, richtig
scheint bei der ganzen Sache, zum Beispiel kann man mit Custom-Firmware mehrere Stockwerke abfackeln
Das, also abfackeln eben vorn von, man kann es benutzen für mehrere Stockwerke, also nicht, also nicht nicht anzünden oder so, ja
Und weil man kann beispielsweise, wenn man beim Erdgeschoss ist, die Karte vom Erdgeschoss laden
und wenn man beim ersten Stock ist, die Karte vom ersten Stock laden, das kann die normale Stock-Firmware gar nicht
Kannst du da eine Kratze jagen? Ach, die hat mittlerweile da kein Schiss mehr vor
Hast du Erfahrungen mit Daten machen? Ja, es geht so, das willst du wissen
Was für einen Staubsauger hast du? Meine Eltern haben sich vor kurzem den Roborock S5 Max geholt
Das war ein Fehler, weil die Custom-Firmware geht bloß für den Roborock S5 oder S50
Die habe ich drauf hier
Die da, also das ist die Software, die ich drauf hab
Und Images hab ich, es gibt so eine fertige Image-Seite für den Staubsauger
Firmware-Images
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo es ist
Es gibt eine Seite, die ist komplett voller Firmware-Images für den Staubsauger
In allen Firmware-Versionen und alles Mögliche, was es gibt, die muss man gar nicht mal selbst machen
Pre-Build-Firmware
Formware
Vielleicht hier?
Firmware?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, irgendeiner, der hat keine Formware
Irgendeiner, der hat eine richtig gute
Ich find's jetzt gar nicht, das ärgert mich
Der hat irgendeiner, der hat eine richtig schöne Übersicht-Seite gemacht
Für den Staubsauger mit Firmwares
Oh nee
Leute, ich werd hier jebaited
Ich werd so krass jebaited
Das Einzige, was das, was das, Chat, Chat
Das Einzige, was ihr davon habt, wenn ihr mich mit Lack jebaited ist
Dass ich das gar nicht mehr mitkriege, wenn das Stream abkackt und ich den Stream nicht wieder online nehm
Das ansonsten hat ja keiner was von
Aber als würd es den Chat jucken, ja
Ähm
Wo ist die Firmware?
Wo gibt's die Firmware-Seite nochmal?
Das ist nämlich sehr praktisch
FAQ
Ich wollt's demjenigen jetzt einfach mal zeigen
Firmware-Downloads
Hier
Ja
Da, genau
Da hast du nämlich für die, für die Generation
Alles drin an Firmware was gibt
Ähm, oh wer
Oh, das kann ich nicht richtig aussprechen
ATK
ATK-Wolle
Ich kann's nicht aussprechen richtig
Äh, trotz
Elite-Speak-Kenntnissen
Dankeschön für den Sub
Es hat wirklich kurz gelackt, aha
Also das lag aber dann nicht an mir
Das lag an Twitch, das gibt nix
Das gibt nix zu lacken gerade
So
Ähm, wer hat das nochmal gefragt
Mit der Firmware vom Staubsauger
Genau, User32DLL
Ja, also der S5 Max, der geht so weit, ich weiß nicht
Aber alle, die den Roborock
Roborock S50
Oder Roborock S5 haben
An Staubsauger
Oder den S
Oder den Vorgänger, die finden hier
Auf der Seite in Gen1 und Gen2
Komplett fertiges Stock-Firmware
Mit ähm, geroutet
Geroutet
Und ähm
Mit Web-Interface
Vorinstalliert
Und wisst ihr was das Coole daran ist, was ich jetzt machen kann
Ich kann jetzt per SSH
Root-Add
Ich kann jetzt per SSH auf meinen Staubsauger
Was
Jaja
Guck mal, ich kann jetzt
Per SSH auf meinen Staubsauger, das ist doch nice
Oder
Und irgendwie und
Was war denn das gerade für ein Saunen oder
Habt ihr das auch gehört
Das hat gerade echt einen komischen Sound gemacht
Das hat irgendwie gerade so bäh
War das die Katze
Warte mal, ich guck mal vor die Tür
Da bist du ja Chico
Hast du keine Maul gemacht
Ja, was ist
Was ist
Ok
Anscheinend, anscheinend war das wirklich meine Katze die gemaulst hat
Aber ihr habt es auch gehört, oder
Ganz merkwürdiges Geräusch
Was war das denn
Also, um jetzt die Sache
Abzuschliessen
Da kriegt ihr alle möglichen Custom-Firmware
Fertig, Pre-Routet
Achso ich wollte ja, achso, äh Passwort! Wow!
So Standard Passwort dafür
Was ist denn ich, weiß ich doch nicht mal was das Standard Passwort dafür ist
Meinst du 123456 bei mir? Nee
Ja da müssen wir hier mal gucken was das Standard Passwort von der Firmware ist
Was ist das Standard Passwort? Root Passwort? Standard Root Passwort?
Für meinen Staubsauger, was ist das Root Passwort für meinen Staubsauger?
Was man nicht alles für Probleme haben kann oder?
Cleaner! Stimmt Cleaner war es glaube ich, genau
Hier man in the middle auf dem, auf dem Staubsauger
Cleaner, du hast recht, Cleaner, ziemlich sicher
Cleaner, da sind wir, Leute, bam!
Token, Leak!
OMFG
Mein Staubsauger Key ist geleakt, jetzt vorbei
Mach mal Aquarium, wollen wir mal gucken ob Ascii Aquarium, ob das Ascii Aquarium auf dem Staubsauger geht
Der Staubsauger darf nicht ins Internet, deswegen ähm mache ich mir da wenig Gedanken, dass irgendjemand mit diesem Kram was anfangen kann vor meinem Staubsauger
Ähm, naja, zumindest, ach komm mal, man kann dich mal clearen
Zumindest Root auf meinem Staubsauger, so muss das sein, ja
Da kann man auch einen Top aufmachen oder so, wenn mein Terminal irgendwie richtig gesetzt wäre
Export Term gleich X Term
Ah guck, man kann den Top aufmachen, man kann den H-Top aufmachen
Und wohlgemerkt, Leute, wir sind gerade auf meinem Staubsauger und gucken uns den Task Manager von meinem Staubsauger an
Ja, so sieht's aus
Ja, äh, so, so ist es
Can it run Crysis?
Das ist, wollen wir mal gucken was da für eine CPU drin ist, im Staubsauger
Da ist
Eine
Ein ARMv7 drinne, das heißt.NET Core wird schon mal drauf laufen, das haben wir sogar mal ausprobieren gemacht
Vier Kerne, ist das richtig?
Ein Quad Core
ARM7
Ist da drinne
Mit, ja, mit wieviel, mit wieviel Takt denn, sieht man das irgendwo, ne, oder?
Hm
Wie, wie, wie, hat jemand, kennt sich da mit jemand aus?
Wie man, wie man die Taktrate davon jetzt rausbekommt?
Benchmarker, ja, ich hab, ich glaub ich hab nix, nix drauf dafür
Da ist ja kaum was drauf
Äh, wie, wie lässt man sich eigentlich den Takt anzeigen?
Wenigst CPU, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob ich den klauen will
Clockspeed
LS, LS-CPU?
Das ist, allen Ernstes?
Hab ich schon nie verwendet
Aber der zeigt mir nix an, der zeigt nur, dass mein Staubsauger einen Vierkerne-CPU hat
Das ist Manjaro mit E3-WM
LSHW ist da bestimmt nicht drauf
Ne, wie dem auch sei, ich wollt jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so sehr auf meinem Staubsauger rüber reiten
Warum sollten ARM-CPUs keinen Takt haben?
Natürlich haben ARM-CPUs einen Takt, wie soll der ohne Takt funktionieren?
Ja, anscheinend zeigt er das nicht an
Äh, CPU-Info haben wir oben gemacht, stand nicht drin
Guck, CPU-Info war hier, steht nicht drin
Kein Takt
So, um nochmal auf die paar Fragen einzugehen
Moin, was ist das für ein Staubsauger? Das ist eine Roborock S50
Irgendwie bekomme ich auf meinem Handy auf dem Homescreen die Google-Search-Panikwerk
Hast du Tipps?
Ne, da hab ich nur wirklich keine Ahnung von
Ähm, das ist kein Problem
Da wird schar
Du kannst ohne Probleme eine.NET Core Anwendung auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen, ist überhaupt kein Problem
Geht, easy, kein Ding
Nur auf dem Zero geht's nicht, auf dem Zero musst du Mono verwenden
Aber auf dem normalen Raspberry ist überhaupt kein Problem, ist genauso angenehm wie auf dem Desktop
Funktioniert wunderbar
Äh, TobiX9919 sagt
War das nicht ein Bug in der Firmware, dass er sich immer resettet?
Ja, war oder ist immer noch, leider
Ähm, aber ich hab jetzt eine Firmware-Kombination genommen
Die Leute haben sich zusammengetan und haben einen Google Docs-Dokument gemacht
Mit welcher Firmware-Version und welchen Settings
Ähm, in welchem Abstand sich das resettet
Und ich hab mir die Kombination rausgenommen, die sich noch gar nicht verpasst
Also insofern hoffe ich mal, es resettet sich nicht
Und wenn es sich resettet, ist auch kein Ding, weil ich hab mir das Token aufgeschrieben
Ich kann es innerhalb von, keine Ahnung, 15 Minuten wieder neu flashen
Ist aber doof, wenn der Staubsauger sich resettet
Und nachdem irgendjemand gefragt hat im Chat, wie einem so langweilig sein kann
Eine Custom-Firmware für den Staubsauger zu programmieren
Muss er sich dann einfach mal auf den Computer aufsetzen
Und dann kann er sich einfach mal aufsetzen
Und dann kann er sich einfach mal aufsetzten
nach der kauf von einem Raspberry Pi 4 oder lieber Pi 3?
Du kannst schon einen Pi 4...
Ja, also es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was es sein soll.
Ähm, für die meisten Anwendungen reicht alles.
Da wird sogar ein Pi 1 reichen, aber der Pi 4 ist halt relativ warm.
Da brauchst du ein ordentliches Gehäuse und Preis-Leistung, also ich denke man kann heute
immer noch ruhigen Gewissens auch zu einem Pi 3 greifen.
Gibt's da OTA-Updates?
Nein, OTA-Updates sind geblockt auf dem Staubsauger, weil OTA-Updates würden den Staubsauger wahrscheinlich
kaputt machen.
Vakuumz.info, sehr seriös, ja das stimmt.
Welche Software verwendest du zum Virtualisieren?
AVMWer Workstation Pro, sogar richtig legit erworben für irgendwann mal 150€ oder so
an Weihnachten im Angebot.
Was sind die Vorteile gegenüber der App?
Naja, die Vorteile gegenüber der App sind, dass du ein Web-Interface hast, das heißt
du kannst den Staubsauger von jedem nur erdenklichen Rechner aus bedienen, Web-Interface gibt's
bei der App nicht, ansonsten musst du halt mit dem Handy machen und du brauchst keine
China-Cloud.
Die App geht ja nicht direkt auf den Staubsauger, die App geht in die China-Cloud und die China-Cloud
zum Staubsauger bzw. der Staubsauger ruft sich aus der China-Cloud die Information ab,
die du mit der App in die China-Cloud gesendet hast und du hast auch ein paar mehr Features
in der Custom-Firma wie im Original, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel, dass du mehrere Schockwerke
machen kannst.
Warum gehst du nicht hin und automatisierst den Staubsauger mit dem Aufzug von deinem
Opa, dass er auf beiden Ebenen saugt?
Den Staubsauger gibt's ja nicht bei dem Fahrstuhl und der Fahrstuhl, der war ja auch nur im
ersten Stock zum Dach.
Ist dein Hostbetrieb System Windows und du virtualisierst Linux oder andersherum?
Mein Host ist Windows und ich virtualisiere Linux.
So rum.
Guck hier, das hier, Host, das Host und das VM.
Ja, stimmt, ich bin gerade, ich hab gerade hochgescrollt, hast du Erfahrungen mit Datenbanken?
Hab ich gesagt, ja, ein bisschen und kam da drauf noch eine Antwort?
Also, ist die Frage, was du wissen willst, nee, anscheinend, anscheinend nicht mehr.
Dann nicht.
Kennst du Unraid?
Ja, kenn ich.
Du hast gerade über.NET Anwendungen geredet.
Du hast eine.NET Anwendung auf dem Pi 3 laufen und die auf dem Pi 4, die.NET Anwendung läuft
auf allen Raspberry Pis.
Bei dem Einser bin ich mir nicht sicher, ich glaube auf dem Einser nicht, aber ansonsten
auf allen außer dem Zero.
Also, es ist egal, ob du einen Zweier, einen Dreier oder einen Vierer kaufst,.NET Core
funktioniert überall auf denen und mit Mono hast du auch eine Runtime für Zero und Pi
1.
Und je nachdem, was du machen willst, ist überhaupt kein Ding, da reicht auch die Rechenleistung
von den Raspberry Pi 1 wahrscheinlich aus.
Schick dich CPU zum Bauer zum Auferklocken.
Das wäre doch mal was, der Bauer übertaktet meinen Staubsauger mit flüssig Stickstoff.
Wie fandest du eigentlich deine Ausbildung?
Oh, das ist jetzt ein bisschen größeres Thema.
Also, wartet mal ganz kurz.
Die Katze ist jetzt drin und hat sich breit gemacht.
Wie fandest du eigentlich deine Ausbildung?
Durchwachsen, ich werde es nicht zu lange ausdehnen und nachdem ich weiß, dass die Aufmerksamkeit
Spanne vieler Leute nicht so hoch ist, mache ich jetzt mal was anderes, was im Hintergrund
passiert.
Also zum Thema Ausbildung muss ich sagen, ich habe die Ausbildung bei einem Provider
gemacht, bei dem ich dann auch ein bisschen gearbeitet habe, aber ich bin danach gewechselt.
Und die Ausbildung an sich, die war gut und schlecht gleichermaßen, sie war insofern schlecht,
weil sich eigentlich keiner so richtig darum gekümmert hat um die Ausbildung, also sprich,
wir hatten da keinen, der groß den Hut auf hat und wir hatten auch keinen, der das groß
koordiniert hat.
Es war sogar manchmal so, dass wir quasi mit den ganzen, wir waren dann irgendwann mal
3 Azubis, dass wir zusammen in ein Büro verfrachtet wurden, wo es hieß und nach dem Motto, es
darf keiner mehr Zeit an die Azubis verschwenden.
Jetzt ohne Mist, das war so die Aussage mal zwischendurch von manchen Chefs da, also dementsprechend
scheiße war die Ausbildung rein von Ausbildungssicht.
Was ziemlich gut war in der Ausbildung, muss man sagen, aber das betrifft, das trifft nur
auf Leute zu, die sich auch für das Thema wirklich interessieren.
Man konnte alles machen, also sprich, wo hast du sonst die Möglichkeit als Azubi mal ins
Rechenzentrum zu gehen, da ein paar Kisten einzubauen, ein paar Glasfasersachen anzuschließen,
ein paar Sachen, so wie du lustig bist großartig, also nicht ganz wie du lustig bist, aber solange
du nichts kaputt machst und aufpasst, eigentlich ohne Probleme, das heißt, wenn du ein bisschen,
den Hang dazu hast, dir Sachen selbst beizubringen, war die Ausbildung eigentlich ziemlich gut,
aber da ist nicht die Firma für verantwortlich, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Ja, wie gesagt, und das war bei einem Provider, deswegen kenne ich mich auch noch so ein bisschen
aus, was Internetgeschichten und Netzwerksachen angeht, obwohl ich damit jetzt schon eigentlich
ziemlich lange nichts mehr zu tun habe und das alles schon outdated ist.
Ich komme mit den Fragen gar nicht her.
Was für einen Staubsauger hast du, wie gesagt, einen Roborock aus S50?
Ist aber doof, wenn der Staubsauger sich resettet, sagt Flintstone, erzähl das mal den älteren
Leuten.
Ich würde es auch keinem, der nicht technikaffin ist, würde ich es auch nicht empfehlen, sich
den Staubsauger zu holen, um den zu flaschen.
Wie kommt man an die Firmware, was ist dir nicht meist so, dass man die nicht bearbeiten
kann, bzw. wie ändert man das, dass man die bearbeiten kann?
Hier, der Hersteller hat da keinen Wert drauf gelegt, großartig, wenn die Hersteller es
einem nicht wirklich schwer machen, ist es kein großartiges Problem, aus einem Firmware-Image
was zu extrahieren.
Da gibt es so schöne Tools wie, was haben wir hier, binwalk, hieß binwalk, oder hieß
das binwalk?
Ganz so weit, wenn man benutzt binwalk, binwalk, ah genau, das Ding, damit kann man Firmware
extrahieren.
Und bei den meisten Firmwares wird man halt eine Linux-Image rausziehen, verschiedene
Partitionen am Ende.
Da kann man das ändern und kann es, je nachdem, was der Hersteller für Schutzvorrichtungen
getroffen hat, auch wieder flaschen.
Macht das Sauger auch gut sauber?
Ja, der ist eh super, ihr müsst euch mal die Reviews durchlesen.
Also wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an, ich mache schon wieder viel zu lange mit dem Staubsauger,
aber eigentlich wollte man nämlich was bestellen.
Der ist richtig gut, das ist preisleistungsmäßig und ich kriege kein Geld für, weil das hätte
ich euch jetzt in den Ref-Link geschickt, einer, in der Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass
man ihn halt auch custom flaschen kann, einer der besten Staubsauger, Roboter-Staubsauger,
die man sich so kaufen kann, ist nicht übertrieben teuer, custom Firmware und hat auch gute
Funktion, also ist wirklich top das Ding.
Übrigens, ratet mal Leute, ratet mal was für ein Betriebssystem auf dem Staubsauger
drauf ist.
Vielleicht wisst ihr es noch, was hat er eigentlich für Schmerzen?
Jaja, jaja, ratet mal was da für ein Betriebssystem drauf ist, also Version, Version, Kali Linux,
Kali Linux ist es nicht.
Debian-mäßig, richtig, richtig, Debian-Schrauber nicht verkehrt, aber nicht ganz, Ubuntu ist
richtig, ja, aber was für ein Ubuntu?
Meint ihr, das ist ein halbwegs aktuelles Ubuntu auf dem Staubsauger?
Ich zeig's euch mal.
Das geht, das ist immer noch supported, 14.04.
Kernel-Version 3.4, das ist schon ein bisschen älter, aber das war nicht der Kernel mit
dem 14.04 ausgeliefert wurde.
Und ich bilde mir ein, es war sogar ursprünglich in der letzten Firmware mal 12.04 und mittlerweile
ist es 14.04.
Also, das sind Zeiten, oder Leute, 2020 ruht auf dem Staubsauger und auf dem Staubsauger
läuft ein Ubuntu 14.04.
So sieht's aus.
Warum so alt, weil die Firmware halt einfach auf dem Stand ist.
Kernel 5.6 und Feuergard drauf, ich mach da nichts drauf.
Was sind deiner Meinung nach coole Projekte für den Raspberry Pi?
Boah, ach du Scheiße, was, was du brauchst ist das beste Projekt.
Also, was ich hab, ich hab, ähm, ich hab nen Raspberry Pi Zero laufen mit der Kamera
fürs Hoftor.
Ich hab, ähm, im Keller auch nen Raspberry Pi Zero laufen, also beides wireless, laufen
für die Heizung, das hab ich euch ja schon gezeigt, ähm, Grafana, das sind die, das
ist die quasi statistische Auswertung von meiner Heizung im Keller.
Das geht über den Raspberry Pi, der per Optolink Kabel vom Hersteller an der Heizung
dran ist.
Da kann man sehr schöne Sachen draus erkennen, so wie warm sind die Abgase, wann macht die
Pumpe was, wann ist der Brenner an, welche Temperatur ist im Kessel, welche Temperatur
hat das Wasser gerade, ja, hier warm aber duschen, so, flupp, dann geht's runter.
Sieht man sofort, ähm, so, und dann hab ich noch nen OctoPie laufen, das ist mein,
das ist ein alter Raspberry Pi, wartet mal, hatte der Raspberry Pi 2 schon WLAN, ne, gell,
dann ist es ein Raspberry Pi 3, den ich da laufen hab.
Was ist das für eine Domain, die du nutzt, eine Domain, die hab ich mir gekauft, aber
wer jetzt auf die Idee kommt, Cloudflare DNS Protected, ähm, aber wieso Resolve die
bei mir zu nichts, hier, HackerMans sind am Start, da musst du jetzt selbst drauf kommen,
warum die bei dir nicht Resolved, ähm, kannst du die auch über HTTPS updaten, wen, was,
kannst du eine Seite zum Domain kaufen empfehlen, nicht wirklich, ich bin bei nem Registrater
sagt, ich bin bei dem hier, die sind ultra billig, aber die haben keine ordentliche DNS
API, was ziemlich doof ist, ähm, deswegen hab ich hier meine Domains registriert, weil
die halt ultra billig sind und mach DNS über Cloudflare. Ja, 14.04 wird glaub noch supported,
glaub 14.04 wird relativ lange support bis 2022 oder, so Ubuntu, äh, achso ich sollte
vielleicht mal richtig schreiben, ah oder auch nicht, ok ich hab nix, irgendein anderes
Ubuntu läuft dann auch übelst lang, oh nee ich hab nix gesagt, guck mal da ist ausgelaufen,
der ist ausgelaufen, äh, tatsächlich, rip, na gut, ich hab nix gesagt, nee, hä, ah,
das ist end of life, wo die wahrscheinlich auch ihre Updates verabschalten und alles,
was meinte ich hier bis 2022 läuft das noch, das weiß ich nicht, ob die Staubsauger Sachen
im Mainline Kernel drin sind, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich haben sie sich deswegen für
die Hardware entschieden, weil es möglichst easy ist. Ja genau, ich war gerade dabei zu
erzählen, also was ich für Raspberry Pi ist, wie gesagt, der erste Raspberry Pi ist, ähm,
also der erste Raspberry Pi den ich hab, der ist, ähm, Kamera für die Tür, fürs, fürs
Hoftor, der zweite, das ist alles, das ist ein 0W, so, der zweite ist die Heizung, Heizung,
Statistik sammeln, das ist auch ein 0W, dann hab ich drittens, das ist ein Raspberry Pi
3, das ist ein Okto, Okto, Pi, ähm, für den 3D Drucker, dann hab ich, das ist zwar
kein Raspberry Pi, aber das zählt auch ungefähr, so, so zu Single Board Computer dabei, ähm,
das ist ein, äh, Ultroid HC2, das ist TV, Headend, äh, Fernseh, Gucken und Aufnehmen,
das steht drüben im Wohnzimmer, haben wir im Stream irgendwann mal zusammen eingerichtet,
haben wir Custom Kernel für komponiert, das war ich noch, ähm, was wurde bis jetzt in
den Warenkorb gepackt, gänzt mich doch, ich bin immer, äh, schnell sidetracked, ähm,
die Raspberry Pies, klar kannst du die warte TPS updaten, ähm, so, du hast, ich hab Unity
Media Kabelfernseher, hab ich sonst noch was, lass mal kurz überlegen, also ich hab jede
Menge ESP32 und ESP866, hab ich hier noch irgendwo einen Raspberry Pi, der jetzt gerade
im Einsatz, achja, klar, natürlich, natürlich, äh, ich hab noch einen Pi 3 im Wohnzimmer
unten, der ist Unify Controller, ähm, und, und, ähm, Kamera Frontend, also das Web Frontend,
wo meine Überwachungskameras drauf sind, läuft da auch, der ist Unify Controller, hab ich
jetzt ganz vergessen, der funktioniert nämlich einfach, so, also das, ich glaub, das war
jetzt alles, wenn ich nicht total was vergessen hab.
Es gibt für VS Code jetzt ein NeoWim Plugin ohne Emulation, das schreib ich mir gleich
mal auf, das probieren wir in einem der Streams mal auf, NeoWim Plugin VS Code, das ist cool,
das probier ich mal aus, so, genau, das sind die Projekte, die ich bei mir auf dem Raspberry
Pi, der hier macht noch ein bisschen mehr anderes Zeug, aber, also der ist jetzt nicht
so der, der erwähnt, also das sind die fünf, ich glaub, ich hab keinen vergessen, das
sind so die fünf Single Board Computer, die ich gerade laufen hab, wie gesagt, noch ein
paar ESP32 und ein paar ESP866, äh, am Laufen, aber Raspberry Pi und ähnliche Konsorten
sind die hier, so, jo, ähm, ja, OctoPi ist ne wirklich super Sache, wenn man nen 3D Drucker
hat, das ist ein Web Interface, wo man, äh, Sketches hochladen kann zum Drucken und gucken
kann, wie weit der Fortschritt ist und sich theoretisch auch über ne Webcam, äh, angucken
kann, was der 3D Drucker grad so macht, das ist wirklich sehr praktisch, äh, welche
Kameras hast du in der Föhnung zur Überwachung, Amazon.com, ich bin froh, wie, immer toll
im Stream, wie wir zu den Sachen kommen, die wir eigentlich machen wollten, aber das find
ich gut, weil das sagt mir, dass ich theoretisch einfach den Stream anschmeißen kann, äh,
trotzdem, ich hoffe zumindest, 200 Leute, denen das gefällt, zugucken und wir absolute
random Themen besprechen und alle sind happy danach, so, ich hab mir davon mal nen 10er
Pack gekauft, also, 10er Pack ist nicht richtig, fünf davon, fünf davon, ich hab's ja schon
ein paar mal gesagt, ich bestell mittlerweile nix mehr einzeln, ich bestell immer nur 3er
Packs, 5er Packs, 10er Packs, ähm, von, von, von Sachen, die halbwegs günstig sind,
ja, also ich bestell mir jetzt keine fünf Fernseh, nur weil ich, da kauf ich mir natürlich
auch ein, logischerweise, ähm, davon hab ich mal fünf Stück davon, fünf Stück davon
gekauft, weil, dann lohnt sich das auch bei Amazon zu bestellen, bei Amazon.com, weil
man bezahlt nochmal, glaub, 15 oder 20 Euro für den Versand, trotzdem ist das deutlich
billiger, als es in Amazon.de gibt, Amazon.de kostet, glaub ich, eine 50 Euro total hängengeblieben,
das lohnt sich nicht, das lohnt sich nicht, äh, warum ich mir die Kameras gekauft hab,
das ist unter der Haube, sind das billigste China-Cams, sieht man ja auch am Preis letztendlich,
sind billigste China-Cams, warum ich mir die gekauft hab, ist, wer hätte es gedacht, weil
es Custom-Firmware gibt, hast du schon mal Probleme mit Zolleinfuhr, ja, hab ich, hatte
ich, und zwar, das letzte Mal, als ich einem in Dreamview, ähm, nee, wie ist das, ah,
die heißt, Ambilight, äh, Dream, Dream, nee, M, wie schreibt man das, M, Ambilight, Dreamscreen,
Dreamscreen, Dreamscreen, hatte ich mir aus den USA bestellt, und die hatten keinen
plasten Schimmer, so eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung für den Fernseh, und die hatten wirklich,
haha, das Bild, alter, haha, das ist ja wieder der absolute Marketing-Wahnsinn, ey, vor allem,
wer, die spielen ja da offensichtlich was drauf, ne, wer spielt denn von denen überhaupt,
da hat keiner einen Controller in der Hand, da hat keiner einen Controller, was zur F***
soll uns das sagen, ja, zumindest, das, das Dreamlight ist wirklich cool, ähm, und das
hab ich bestellt, die hat keine Ahnung, wie man das richtig nach Deutschland verschifft,
und das ist beim Zoll gelandet, und da musste ich dem Zoll-Typ erklären, dass da kein Fernseh
drin ist, das war ja auch so ein Abenteuer für sich, das, das war ja echt auch so ein
Abenteuer für sich, ich hab das bestellt, und das kam an, und das landet beim Zoll,
also, und wenn ihr zum Zoll geht, dann fragt, der darf ja nicht aufmachen, also, das muss
der ja mit euch zusammen aufmachen, und dann hat er mich gefragt, ja, was ist das denn,
und ich hab gesagt, das ist eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung für den Fernseh, da, übrigens, bei mir
noch nicht 4K, ich hab nur die 1080p Variante, ich hab mir gesagt, hier, das ist eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung
für den Fernseh, und dann hat er dann angefangen zu gucken in seiner Tabelle, ja, ok, Fernseh,
Fernseh, und ich hab gesagt, nein, nein, das ist kein Fernseh, das ist eine Beleuchtung
für den Fernseh, also im Prinzip sind das ein paar LED-Lichter, ja, hm, als was, als
was, äh, kann man das denn jetzt kategorisieren, aber ich hab zu ihm gesagt, ja, er soll einfach
mal gucken, ob es irgendwie einfach Beleuchtung oder so gibt, und, alter, war das ein Akt,
und am Ende, am Ende hab ich, glaub ich, fast das Doppelte bezahlt, äh, für den ganzen
Scheiß, lass mal kurz gucken, was kosten denn, was kosten denn eine neue Variante, äh, wo
kann man hier was kaufen, why, wo, wo kauft man da hier was, kann es sein, dass die wegen
Corona grad dicht sind, is Creamscreen dead, oh, oh, die gibt's nicht mehr, oh, rip, ha,
nein, ach, die sind tatsächlich, die sind tot, oder was, ach ja, oh, rip, okay, die
gibt's gar nicht mehr, ich muss mal gucken, ob es da was Vergleichbares gibt, das Produkt
war nämlich sehr, sehr nice, ja, ja, tatsächlich, echt blöd, dass es die nicht mehr gibt,
weil die waren ziemlich gut, nun ja, ähm, das hab ich bestellt, und es war ein Riesenakt,
bis, bis ich das mit dem Zoll raus hatte, was da, was da Sache ist, ja, voll für'n Arsch,
voll für'n Arsch, ja, und am Ende, ich sag jetzt einfach mal irgendeinen Preis, ja, ich
hab's bestellt für 120 Euro, am Ende hab ich irgendwie 220 oder so bezahlt, da kommt
ja, es gibt ja, es gibt ja so komische Staffelungen, ich glaub, bis 20 Euro, bis 20 Euro ist es
gar nichts, ab 20 Euro bis 105 oder 150 Euro bezahlst du normale Mehrwertsteuer drauf, und
ab 105 oder 150 Euro, ich glaub, 150 Euro, bezahlst du, ähm, Mehrwertsteuer und Zollgebühren
drauf, so, und da zählen, und das ist wichtig, da zählen Versandkosten dabei, da zählen
Versandkosten dabei, deswegen war ich bei 150 Euro, da musste das Ganze irgendwie klassifizieren,
und, ähm, am Ende hab ich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 200, noch was bezahlt, bei ursprünglich
140 oder so, also, es hat sich überhaupt gar nicht gelohnt, das zu kaufen.
Das Feldende 2020, echt jetzt, meine Fresse, die gönnen einem ja nix, die gönnen einem
ja gar nix, nicht immer bis 20 Euro kostenlose Zollgeschichten, nix gönnen einem, ja, genau,
also das sind die Kameras, die ich hab, übelste billige Crap-China-Cams, eigentlich überhaupt
nicht gut, aber für den Preis gut, und, warum hab ich mir die gekauft, weil, Custom-Firmware,
ihr wisst ja, ich betreib fast alles, was es gibt, was ansonsten nur mit China-Cloud-App
oder irgendwie Zwangs-Online-Modus funktionieren würde, betreib ich nur mit Custom-Firmware,
oder ich kauf's mir nicht, und die haben eine ganz gute Custom-Firmware für die Kameras,
deswegen hab ich mir die gekauft.
Dein Auto hat schon Custom-Firmware, mein Auto ist so alt, das hat überhaupt keine
Firmware, ich hab euch doch mal mein Auto gezeigt, das ist so alt, das hat keine Firmware,
Alter, falls dann auch noch die Farbe, ne, da brauchste keine Firmware bei dem Ding,
das Einzige, was der Zusatzkennzeichen liegt, genau, GG, GG, thanks, das Einzige, was bei
der, was bei dem Auto, smart, in Anführungsstrichen ist, ist ein Stecker, Zigarettenanzünderstrom
zu USB, dass man ein Navigationsding halt vom Handy längere Zeit benutzen kann.
Opel Agila S kommt in die Gruppe, Bluetooth, ne, Kabel, YouTube GameStar Battlefield 5
Sommer Update wird letztes Update sein, das wissen wir schon, solltet ihr mal ein BMW
holen, um unsere Wirtschaft anzukurbeln, ne, dafür gärn ich meine Kohle nicht aus, gibt
es eigentlich eine Mrs.
Wubblors oder soll es die nicht geben, aktuell gibt es keine, ob es mal wirklich eine Frau
Max FPS Wubblors wie auch immer geben wird, hängt davon ab, ich hab's nicht vor, ich
hab ehrlich gesagt, schon seit ich klein bin, hab ich mir gesagt, ich will niemals heiraten,
was ich mit meinen Eltern mitgekriegt hab damals, was das für ein Akt war und auf dem
Stand bin ich auch heute noch, allerdings, es ist ja so, wenn erstmal die Hormone mit
einem durchgehen und man sich so halb in geistiger Umnachtung befindet, dann kann man es nicht
ausschließen, dass man doch mal so blöd ist und zu heiraten, also ich hab's nicht vor,
ich hab's echt nicht vor, zu heiraten und ich hab auch nicht vor, irgendwelche Kinder
zu kriegen, weil mir Kinder prinzipiell einfach nur auf den Keks gehen und ich Menschen an
sich nicht mag und Kinder am allerwenigsten, Kinder der Scammer, ich mein, manchmal mach
ich mir schon so Gedanken, so, okay Max, was machst du mal, wenn du irgendwie, was machst
du mal, wenn du keine Ahnung, 60, 70 bist, ja, keine Amtsstaat, keine Frau, keine Kinder,
keine großartige Verwandtschaft, ja, und wisst ihr was ich dann mache, dann hol ich mir
ein MMO-Abo und spiele den ganzen Tag MMO oder sowas, nee, keine Ahnung, Spaß beiseite,
da mach ich mir schon so ein bisschen Gedanken drüber, aber ich hab's einfach nicht so,
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch an das Weihnachtsgrill
von vor ein paar, von zwei Jahren war das, wo ich ein bisschen was erzählt hab im Stream,
da ist ja auch nix draus geworden, ich bin einfach unfähig oder unmotiviert, schräg
Strich unfähig, was zwischenmenschliche Interaktion angeht, vielleicht gibt's ja Custom-Firmware
für mich, vielleicht gibt's ja Custom-Firmware, die ich flaschen kann, dass das nicht mehr
so ist, wie wär's, wie wär's eine Thai zu heiraten, was heißt, was hat denn die Herkunft
damit zu tun, ich will nicht heiraten, weil ich nicht heiraten will, nicht weil die Herkunft
dann nicht passt, das kann man noch alles üben, jaja, natürlich, ja klar, aber man
muss es wollen, und ich will überhaupt nicht, es ist ja nicht so, als wär ich unglücklich
dadurch, dass ich wenig mit Leuten zu tun hab, ich will mit Leuten nix zu tun haben,
ich mag absolut, das ist kein Witz, ich sag das ja immer so wieder, so nebenbei aus Scherz,
so dass ich andere Menschen nicht mag, aber das ist so, und ich hab auch überhaupt nicht
vor das zu ändern, außer den Chat natürlich, den Chat, den Chat ist natürlich der beste,
ja.
Was ist denn das für ne Username, alter, der Username, Leute.
Der Username ist ja geil. Hobbydelen ist mein Anus.
Was ist mit den Leuten los ey?
Achso Obo, ne ne ne da habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken zu gemacht.
PC Lustig sagt, mir geht es sehr ähnlich wie dir, aber dann habe ich mich rausgetraut und mit
Menschen gesprochen. Jetzt mag ich es sehr. Bei mir ist es umgedreht. Bei mir ist es umgedreht.
Ich habe mich dazu früher gezwungen, das zu machen. Sei es jetzt, irgendwelche
Weihnachtsfeiern mitzumachen oder irgendwelche Events zu gehen oder irgendwelche Konzerte,
Festivals. Sonst war es, ich habe mich da gezwungen hinzugehen, weil ich gedacht habe,
das ist normal, das macht man so. Und es hat mich immer übelst angekotzt,
die ganze zwischenmenschliche Interaktion und wie hängen geblieben die meisten Menschen so sind,
dass ich mich jetzt bewusst, dazu musste ich aber auch erst mal 30 plus werden,
dass ich das kapiert habe, dass ich mich jetzt bewusst dazu entschieden habe zu sagen Scheiß
drauf. Ich gehe auch auf keinen Sommerfest, auf keine Weihnachtsfeier von der Firma zum
Beispiel, oder auch nicht auf irgendwelche Ach lass noch mal hier irgendwo hingehen Events
oder sonst was. Das einzige, was ich ab und zu mal mache ist, ich höre mir irgendwelche
Musik an. Frankfurt war mein Iron Maiden Konzert. Wir wollten ja auch wieder auf ein Iron Maiden
Konzert gehen in Köln. Ja, solche Sachen. Also das mache ich manchmal, aber das ist auch das
einzige. Und das liegt einfach daran, weil mir zwischenmenschliche Interaktion echt
auf den Keks geht. Es ist nicht so, dass ich sage, ich würde ja gerne, aber irgendwie kann
ich nicht oder so. Ich will nicht. Richtig. Strafraumprediger. Wenn irgendwelche
Firmenveranstaltungen sind, bin ich der Erste, der sagt, wir haben auch auf der Arbeit Leute,
die sind da richtig, richtig happy. Die gehen da gerne hin. So nach dem Motto ist es wieder
Sommerfest. Ich melde mich jetzt schon mal an, bevor es die Teilnehmerliste gibt. Am besten
gleich mit ganzer Familie anmelden. Es gibt Leute, die finden das geil und freuen sich. Das ist
schön, das soll jeder machen, aber im Umkehrschluss auch eben nicht. Und ich versuche es ja auch
keinem aufzuzwängen, dass man das so machen muss wie ich. Ich denke mir, wer da Spaß dran hat,
soll das machen, aber die Leute sollen mich in Ruhe lassen. Soll das heißen, du hast keine
Freunde und machst auch nichts mit denen. Naja, also ich habe schon ein paar Leute, mit denen ich
mich ganz gut verstehe. Ich habe auch ein paar Freunde, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir da
uns alle Wochenende oder so bis auf und gehen. Ich gehe ja mal noch davon aus, dass diese ganze
Geschichte, dass ich YouTube Sachen angefangen habe oder jetzt auch diese ganze Streaming-Geschichte,
dass das schon so ein bisschen Ausdruck dessen ist, dass ich keinen Bock habe auf RL Leute.
Könnte ich auch irgendwas anderes machen. Easykiller sagt, bei uns machen die Sommerfeste
immer während der Arbeitszeiten und machen die verpflichtend. Grip. Kannst du nicht einfach sagen,
ich arbeite lieber. Das kann dich doch keiner zwingen auf Sommerfest zu gehen. So, es gab
oben noch ein paar andere Sachen. Bis dahin gibt es schon gute Roboter mit Custom-Firma, weil es
bis ich 80 bin oder so, das stimmt. Tomix9919, Prime, zwei Monate, Dankeschön. Huge Subscriber.
Heiraten in World of Warcraft. Das erinnert mich an meine MMO-Zeit. Oh meine Güte, da will ich
überhaupt nicht drüber nachdenken. So, davor hatten wir das mit dem Zoll. Oh, guck mal hier,
der hs-yuri hat geschrieben, muss mich auch noch bedanken, hatte gestern ein Bewerbungsgespräch
und wurde gefragt, was Nachteile von Couponetes und Docker sein können. Als erster sind mir da
deine Argumente in den Kopf gekommen, dass nicht jede kleinste Anwendung einen eigenen Container
braucht. Und das war genau, was er hören wollte. Da hattest du Glück, dass du einen sitzen hattest
mit Verstand. Es gibt bestimmt auch so viele, die dem Docker- und Container-Hype so extrem
nachrennen, dass sie sagen, selbst LS muss im Container laufen und so was in der Richtung. Aber
da hattest du wenigstens mit Verstand sitzen gehabt. Ja, und neben sie dich? War das Bewerbungsgespräch
für eine Ausbildung oder für einen Job? Aber Poggers auf jeden Fall, huge.
Kurz vor dem Sommerfest Stromstecker vom Server verstecken und versuchen zu... Das ist keine gute
Idee aktuell. Die sind eh bei uns gerade ein bisschen angepisst, dass es so viele Ausfälle
gegeben hat. Wie synchronisierst du eigentlich deine Keypass-Satei? Next Cloud. Moin, Arte Brate.
In Luxemburg gibt es dafür den Pax Steuervorteile ohne Heirat. Was? Echt? Nice. Vielleicht soll
in Luxemburg. Die haben auch wenig Corona. Aha, für deine Bachelorarbeit habe keine
Zusage, aber klang sie ja da. Das ist doch nice. Und wie dumm ist es, die Datei auf Dropbox
hochzuladen? Naja, ich würde es aus... Es ist nicht blöd. Du kannst deinen Keypass schon
über Dropbox sünden. Aber ich überlege mir immer, wie sicher ist mein Passwort wirklich?
Und zweitens, wie sicher ist die Verschlüsselung von dem, was ich da hochgeladen habe, in 15
Jahren noch? Dementsprechend ist das Beste, wenn man die Datei verschlüsselt, aber nicht
unnötig schert überall. Es wird sich unterm Strich keine Sau für deine Keypass-Datei interessieren,
aber man weiß ja nie. Man muss es ja nicht drauf anlegen. Aber du kannst schon über
Dropbox sünden, wenn du sonst keine Möglichkeit hast. Ich sünde die aber eh nicht extern,
ich sünde die nur bei mir im W-Lan und das mache ich über NextClaw. Kannst du mal ein
Update zu deinem Serverraum machen? Da gibt es auch kein großartiges Update. Aber in Luxemburg
hast du Maske de Protection. Ja, das haben wir ja gelernt. Reden die Französisch? Reden
die in Luxemburg nicht so eine komische Hybrid-Geschichte aus Deutsch, Französisch und Englisch oder
sowas? Natürlich Dropbox mit 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung. Ne, ne, also die 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung
ändert daran ja nichts. Die 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung ist ja nur, ist in Anführungsstrichen sichere
für dich beim Einloggen. Einmal angenommen, irgendjemand kommt an deine Keypass-Datei dran
und zumindest Dropbox kommt dran. Dann hast du halt die Keypass-Verschlüsselung immer
noch, die nicht schlecht ist, die mit Sicherheit auch wahrscheinlich nie geknackt wird in
den nächsten paar Jahrzehnten, wenn es ein ordentliches Passwort ist. Aber man weiß
es nicht. Und zumindest Dropbox hat Zugriff und mit Sicherheit jede Menge andere auch,
wenn sie es drauf anlegen, wo Dropbox halt mitarbeiten muss. Wie gesagt, ich glaube
nicht, dass sich jemals jemand für deine Keypass-Datei interessiert. Aber muss ich
immer fragen, wenn man das irgendwo schert, was ist die Verschlüsselung in 15 Jahren
auch wert, mit der es verschlüsselt ist und wie sicher ist dein Passwort wirklich?
Skillkiller sagt, ich habe ein Ubuntu 20.04 virtualisiert, aber wenn ich das Anwendungsmenü
öffnen lädt, das immer recht langsam und alles geht voll schnell. Keine Ahnung. Wann
gibt es noch? Wann gibt es Sonntag-Laber-Stellz mit dem Friseur? Ja, wenn der Friseur wieder
was aufnehmen will, gibt es da auch was. Aber da hat der aktuell keinen Bock. Teste zur
Zeit Android. Hast du Erfahrungen mit Android? Nee. Ich weiß, was es ist. Ich habe es mir
schon angeguckt, habe ich aber keine großartigen Erfahrungen mit. Keypass größer Lastpass?
Ja. Allein schon, weil das nicht Cloud-Flicht ist. Wolltest du nicht was bestellen? Doch.
Ich komme mit dem Chat nicht hinterher. Bitwarden ist auch okay, wenn man unbedingt was haben
will, was online ist. Ist das Pokemonbook? Ich glaube schon. Also das davor kann schon
sein. Hast du mal was mit QEMU gemacht und GPU-Paththrough? Ja, habe ich gemacht. Also
mit KVM. KVM-GPU-Paththrough habe ich schon gemacht. Funktioniert ohne Probleme, wenn
das passende Mainboard hast. Was hältst du von Enpass? Nichts mehr. Habe ich mal ganz
kurz verwendet. Halte ich aber nichts mehr von, weil die sich ewig davor gedrückt haben,
einen Security-Audit zu machen. Und glaube ich mittlerweile auch immer noch nicht alles
veröffentlicht haben. Kann aber sein, dass ich da falsch liege und man nicht so richtig
schlaut raus geworden ist und man im Endeffekt immer noch nicht genau weiß, was die App so
treibt. Alles was nicht Open Source ist und irgendwie nicht quasi in deiner Infrastruktur
drinnen bleibt, finde ich gerade für Passwortsync nicht tauglich. So, du wolltest ja RTX Voice
im Stream testen, kann ich machen. Aber nicht jetzt. Jetzt wollte ich noch ein bisschen
China-Kram gucken. Cbit 6 Monate, Dankeschön. Excellent Subscriber. Oh, es hat geleckt Leute,
ich sehe es. Ah, F. F. Lack. Ah Leute, Lack. Unity Media.
Oh ja, es geht wieder los Leute. Unity Media ist wieder im Umsprachen, das dauert jetzt
wieder 5 Minuten.
So ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt wieder. Hat kurz gedauert. Oh nee, oh, oh, oh, 105,
wie kann man über 100% haben? Okay, ich muss noch kurz Bandbreite runterstellen.
Ah, okay. So.
Oh nee.
Komm, hoffentlich hat es nicht jetzt. Du wolltest doch nicht was bestellen, das ist korrekt.
Nur 5% CPU Usage, ja. Ja, was soll jetzt gerade großartig CPU benutzen? Passiert ja
nichts. So, um aber zur eigentlichen China-Bestell-Geschichte zurückzukommen. Master of Side-Checking,
ja das stimmt. Und wahrscheinlich die Hälfte hier an Fragen wieder nicht beantwortet haben.
Genau, also um aber zurückzukommen, was China-Bestellen angeht. Also ich hatte jetzt gar nicht so ganz
konkret was vor. Eine Sache habe ich letztens gesehen in einem YouTube-Video, das fand
ich echt nice. Was? Foldable Smartphone. Was ist das? Das sieht da mega hässlich aus.
Das letzte, eine coole Sache habe ich letztens in einem YouTube-Video gesehen. Du hast schon
ein Ubuntu 20.04 VM. Nö, habe ich nicht. Wir haben mal eine gemacht im Stream, haben
uns das ein bisschen angeguckt. Ich habe letztens was cooles gesehen und zwar ein D-Solar-Tool.
Das war so eine, das war quasi ein Lötkolben mit einer Pumpe dabei. Ähm, aber es ist irgendwie
nichts dabei. Das war richtig cool. Nö, es lag nicht. Oh, es laggt. Oh fuck, auf einen
Schlag auf 38%. Vodafone, leck mich doch am Arsch. So ein dreckiger Scheißladen. Es
kann doch nicht sein, dass ich abends um 21.30 nicht mit 1,9 MBit streamen kann. 1,9 MBit,
wir sind nicht in Uganda. Was soll der Scheiß denn? Wechsel zur Telekom. Die hat halt deutlich
weniger Bandbreite bei mir, das ist halt die Scheiße. Du hast die Auswahl zwischen Kacke
und Kacke. Uganda Hosting macht 2,5 garantiert, Uganda Hosting macht wahrscheinlich sogar
5 garantiert. Das wäre doch mal ein guter Name für eine Firma, oder? Uganda Hosting.
Das gibt's ja wirklich. Zulul. Guck mal, was es kostet bei Uganda. Uganda Hosting was
zu hosten. What? Cloud Server, Uganda Hosting. Was kriegen wir denn da? Der Uganda Hosting
X 65.000 monatlich. Oh, das ist die Währung. Ich dachte der Server heißt so. Das ist die
Währung, oder? UKX. Was ist das in Euro? 2 Euro. 15 Euro? Was gibt's für 15 Euro im
Alter? 512 MB RAM? Ein Core? Das ist ja Wucher. Ja gut, ich meine dafür ist es in Uganda.
Die Leute die in Uganda was hosten lassen, die wissen schon wahrscheinlich warum sie
das da hosten lassen. Zulul. Das ist schon echt teuer. Das ist echt teuer. Aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Leute, die dort was hosten lassen, ganz genau wissen,
was sie da hosten lassen und es deswegen in Uganda hosten lassen. Qualität hat seinen
Preis. Check mal bei 5G. Was? 5G? 5G. Guck mal, sogar in Uganda kriegen die Kabel verlegt.
Viel steht da aber nicht. Ach, sie bauen das gerade aus. About Us. Down for maintenance.
Die About Seite ist down for maintenance. Kriegsschreib check ich nicht. Was lässt
man am besten in Uganda hosten? Das weiß ich auch nicht. Ich kenne mich in dem Bereich
nicht aus, was man da hosten lässt. Ich habe da ein paar Ideen, aber ich will da keine
auf Ideen bringen, deswegen zähle ich da nichts zu. Ok, Uganda Hosting, alles klar.
Ok, den Blitzwolf hatten wir, da sind wir irgendwie bei einem Staubsauger gekommen und dann kam
eins zum anderen. Da gab es noch so eine Drone Racing Maske. Flash Steals Everyday. Gibt
es da nur 4 Stück? Das ist aber wenig. Ach ne, hier. Ach guck mal, da gibt es die Drohne
gleich dazu. Da kann man sich eine Drohne, ist aber keine Racing Drohne. Die Soldat ja,
aber die hatten nix. Die hatten irgendwie nix. Ah Moment, sowas hier habe ich letztens
gesehen. Im Video sah das sehr praktisch aus. Das ist im Endeffekt so eine Art Löt, aber
nicht so billig wie das hier. Das andere, was ich im Video gesehen habe, war schon ein
bisschen besser. Das ist im Prinzip eine Lötkoll mit Spitze, es macht heiß und hinten ist eine
Pumpe dran, die saugt das Lötzinn ab. Eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee. So ein billig Ding
könnte man sich mal bei Banggood bestellen. Das brauche ich eh nur alle 5 Jahre mal. Aktuell
habe ich sowas hier. Aktuell mache ich es so, ich habe ein bisschen Kupfer und so eine
Saugepumpe. Damit kriegt man das auch weg, aber so ein Tool wäre glaube ich viel praktischer.
Und wir waren hier gerade noch beim Must Buy. Nee, müssen muss ich das gar nicht. Leute,
25, äh 50 Mundschutze für 25 Dollar, das ist doch mal was oder? Easy Money. Pock. Kost
250 zu bestellen. Guck mal Leute, in China geht es denen mittlerweile schon so gut, dass
sie neue Mundschutze herstellen können und sie in neun Tagen zu uns verschiffen. Hat
die Pumpe Customfirma, die Pumpe ist offline. Ich brauche keine Customfirma. Die können
in China mittlerweile schon neue Mundschutze herstellen. Oh guck mal, 66% off. Oh, huge.
Cut it into two pieces, cut it in two pieces. האל, Ultimately sind 23www.
...
Huge, Super Mario World Musik
Das ist nicht das... ist das das Overworld Theme1?
Nee
Dass.. nein, das ist nicht das Overworld Theme!
Fake News
Fake News, dass Over..
Das ist, das ist Levelmusik. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Mario World Overworld Theme.
Das Overworld Theme ist, ist, ähm, dieses, dieses, ähm...
Dö, dö, dö, dö...
Ähm, Moment.
Das ist nicht das Overworld Theme, WTF?
Da...
Das ist nicht das Overworld Theme. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das stimmt nicht. Fake News.
Das Overworld Theme geht anders.
Ich...
Let's play Super Mario World. Das Overworld Theme ist was anderes.
Ja, meinetwegen auch Domtendo.
Kann ich mir sonst zwar nicht angucken, aber ich will einfach nur die Musik hören.
Ja.
Wo ist, wo ist die Overworld?
Ja, hier Overworld. Achtung.
Hört ihr?
Das ist andere Musik. Das ist nicht das Overworld Theme.
Fake News.
Das habe ich auch nicht durchgesetzt, muss man sagen.
Das ist, das ist das Overworld Theme.
Da hatte der Tanuki noch mal weitere Auftritte und die Federn nicht.
Äh, überall Fake News.
Jetzt haben wir die wichtigsten Sachen auch noch mal geklärt heute.
Ansage an Domtendo.
Aber selbst wenn, da kann er doch überhaupt nichts für. So Leute, bestellen wir uns eine Runde Masken.
25 Dollar. 25 Dollar. Guck mal. 20 Euro. 20 Dollar für neue Benutzer.
Das heißt, ihr bezahlt 5 Dollar für 50 Masken. Und sie kommen angeblich in 30 Tagen an.
Das lohnt sich nicht wirklich, oder?
Oder 18 Dollar für ungefähr 10, 20 Tage mit Processing Time.
Was, ich soll das auf Twitter posten, um Leute zu triggern?
Oh nee, da habe ich schon genug Leute getriggert.
Entlötlitze. Ja, da habe ich welche.
Du meinst diese Kopferspule. Also diese, die aufgewickelten Kopfer...
Kopfer...
Litze.
Ja, da habe ich welche.
Von den Funktionen auch. Die Funktionen auch ganz gut.
So, ähm, ja. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also das letzte, was ich bei AliExpress bestellt habe, war das hier.
Und das ist jetzt schon seit irgendwie, weiß nicht, einem Monat oder so auf dem Weg.
Das hier habe ich zuletzt bei AliExpress bestellt.
Ähm, das ist ein, ich meine die Beschreibung ist ja, ist schon wieder, ist schon wieder kompletter Fail, ja.
Also generell, die Beschreibung auf den China Seiten und die, äh, und die Bilder, die sind te...
Warum kann man das Bild nicht groß machen?
Guck mal.
Note, extreme high pressure, 22 Volt.
What? Was wollte mir genau mitteilen?
Mit, mit, ähm, dann haben wir Voltage, 3,5 bis 20 Ampere.
What?
Ok, geh mal voraus, hier haben sie sich verschrieben, da sollte ein Volt stehen.
Aber selbst dann, ähm, aber selbst dann, ja ich weiß schon wie die auf Druck kommen, aber trotzdem, das ist mega Fail.
Und, aber selbst dann, wenn du, also erst mal 20 Volt USB, ich glaube theoretisch könnte der Maximum Quick Charge, ähm,
also der aller, aller neuste Quick Charge Standard, der macht glaube ich, der geht glaube ich bis, theoretisch maximal spezifizierten 20 Volt, aber ich glaube es gibt kein Gerät was das kann.
Ähm,
zumindest, zumindest gehen wir mal von aus, das wäre wirklich so, 20, 20 Volt, 5 Ampere, das wären dann Maximum theoretisch 100 Volt, aber im Leben nicht über dieses Ding.
Das, das glaube ich denen nicht.
Das glaube ich denen nicht.
Ähm,
was heißt, da steht so ein Mist und dann Max denkt sich erst mal drauf, ne ich hab ein Video dazu gesehen.
Ich hab ein Video dazu gesehen und was das ist, nur mal, nur mal zur Erklärung, also, ähm, guck mal, da kriegt man, da kriegt man normale Relays, ne, kriegt man nicht gezeigt, das ist Batterielade Modul.
Also, es gibt ja, diese Sonoff Dinger, die kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich, Sonoff, äh, ja, so diese Dinger, Sonoff Basic.
Das ist im Prinzip ein Schalter, ein Relay, was ihr übers, übers WLAN schalten könnt. Das ist ganz nützlich, wenn ihr beispielsweise Geräte habt, die ihr ein- und ausschalten wollt übers WLAN, äh, die halt selbst nicht smart sind.
Vielleicht kennt das der eine oder andere. Und das sind quasi so ähnliche Dinge halt nur, dass man USB-Geräte ein- und ausschalten kann.
Ich dachte mir, ist ganz praktisch, können wir mal bestellen. Und wie ich halt so bin, hab ich natürlich gleich wieder 10 Stück bestellt.
Weil ich ja immer 10er-Packs bestelle, hab ich ja schon erzählt. Und das kostet halt auch glücklicherweise nicht viel.
Wenn du 10 Stück bestellst, dann macht man das Ganze hier über, äh, ich hab's mit Tracking bestellt, wahrscheinlich das hier, vermute ich mal.
So, kostet am, what? Ja, kostet dann am Ende irgendwie 40, 45 Dollar oder so oder Euro für 10 Dinger.
Dachte ich mir, kann man sich mal holen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wann die kommen. Weil ich will, ich bin da echt scharf mal auszuprobieren.
Das Problem beim what ist, dass man Max nicht live jebaiten kann. Das stimmt. Wir hatten heute noch gar kein Scamtrain.
Warum war heute das Scamtrain noch nicht da? Zu wenig Prime-Subs. Ich das richtig seh.
Schaust du eigentlich gar nicht auf eine CE-Zertifizierung? Hey, bei AliExpress, die drucken dir alle, die drucken dir alle Zertifizierungen drauf, die es gibt.
Da kannst du nichts drauf geben. Bei AliExpress ist alles immer zertifiziert, obwohl nichts zertifiziert ist.
Ozone-Generator? Was genau ist ein Ozone-Generator? Ozone-Generator.
Genau. Ein Heizlüfter, oder? Nee, was ist das? Moment, was? Was ist das?
Gerüche entfernen? Boah, was es alles gibt? Gleich mal bestellen. Nee, braucht man nicht.
Du bist Fahr-Informatiker, System-Integration. Hab ich mal gelernt, ja? Korrekt.
Korrekt. Wir wissen ja, dass wir nicht nach Huge-USB suchen dürfen bei AliExpress. Weil bei Huge-USB findest du gleich solche Dinger. Was auch immer das mit Huge-USB zu tun hat.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind. Ich hab letztens in einem Stream FFZ-Emotes, hab ich den Emote gesehen.
Hab ich mir auch gedacht, ich glaube, das ist das anstößigste und gleichermaßen eigentlich doch wiederum nicht Emote, was ich je gesehen hab hier bei FFZ. Salami. Nee. Was, bei der Twitch-TV?
Äh, wie sucht man hier? Ah, wie sucht man hier? Kann man nicht suchen? Hier, Salami.
Letztens war ich in einem Stream drinnen und auf einmal kam irgendwie einer mit diesem komischen Salami-Emote um die Ecke. Nein, wir haben kein Salami-Emote.
Sofort. Nee, ich hab's mir kurz überlegt. Hyper Salami. Ich hab's mir kurz überlegt, aber das atet dann wieder aus im Chat.
Ich mach's auf den Discord. Genau, wir machen's auf dem Discord, da können die Leute schon mal üben. Also, das Emote zu benutzen.
Da geht der Chat. Da freut sich der Chat. Da freut sich der Chat. Das war mir klar, das war mir klar.
Hat AliExpress dann wieder Angebote auch zum Tag der Arbeit? Weil gerade in China ist doch bestimmt Tag der Arbeit und so das doch. Da müssen sie nach der Arbeit nicht in den Käfig.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon lob genug dann. Blitzt die jetzt? Ah, exzellent. Echte, echte AliExpress Gold-Uhr. Ja klar. Was'n das für ne riesen Taschenlampe? Da kannste ja einer mit erschlagen.
What the fuck? Was ist das für ne Taschenlampe? Die ist dreimal so groß wie ne Hand. Wollt ihr mich verämmeln? Das ist im Leben.
Die Musik. Leute, die Musik dabei. Nee, das ist ne ganz normale Taschenlampe. Die ist überhaupt nicht so groß. Guck mal, die ist überhaupt nicht so groß.
Die AliExpress Produktbilder wieder. Guck dir schon das Produktbild an. Bäm. Und das ist ne, das war einfach ne kleine Hand. Also das muss dann aber eine Mikroskop-Hand sein. Das ist ne Mini-Hand. Hobbit-Hand. Keine Ahnung, so klein kann das gar nicht. Selbst die Chinesen hatten die nicht so klein im Vergleich zu dem anderen.
Exzellent Photoshop. Ja, ich glaube ich auch. Guck mal, es gibt mehr. Leute, es gibt mehr. Es gibt anscheinend wirklich so fette. 17cm. Nice.
Mächtigsten LED-Scheinwerfer. 5 LED-Kopflampe. Also die Beschreibungen sind immer absoluter Wahnsinn. Uhren, die kein Mensch braucht. Oh, es geht ja noch weiter.
Uhren, LED-Lampe, Auto, RC-Cars. Im Leben würde ich mir diese Lötkolben nicht kaufen. Also das ist ja mittlerweile ne Sache. Ich dachte mir früher auch immer, ne ordentliche Lötkolben oder ne ordentliche Lötstation, das ist verschwendetes Geld.
Habe ich mir früher immer so gedacht. So, das lohnt sich doch eigentlich gar nicht. Kannst auch so ein 15€ Lötkolben kaufen. Aber ich muss euch sagen, Leute, seid nicht mir die...
...Nano. Nachdem ich mir das Teil gekauft habe, muss ich sagen, weiß ich eine gute Lötstation und gute Handhabung bei Lötkolben erst zu schätzen.
Das ist extrem geil, das Teil. Guckt euch mal die Lötkolben an. Das ist ein super elastisches Kabel. Und der Lötkolben selbst ist halt auch sehr klein. Der ist nicht viel größer als ein dicker Stift.
Das heißt, du bist auch super agil damit, zig verschiedene Spitzenaufsätze, die es dafür gibt. Also richtig nice, das Teil. Es gibt auch die kleinere Variante für 150€. Das kann ich empfehlen, das lohnt sich wirklich das Teil, wenn man öfters mal was lötet. Such mal nach Flashlight. Alter, Chat wieder.
Ja, also das kann ich wirklich empfehlen, die Lötstation. Und da scheißt der AliExpress 10€ Lötkolben da sowas von dagegen ab, das glaubt ihr gar nicht.
Die Erser Lötstation, die habe ich eingestellt auf 380°C. Das fällt mir nur gerade ein, weil ich gerade sehe, dass Leute 380 Kekspoints ausgeben im Chat. Die steht bei mir auf 380°C und das Ding ist in 5-10 Sekunden auf Temperatur. Das ist ultra geil, das Teil. Also nicht das, das was ich euch gerade gezeigt habe. Das ist Drab.
Oh, eine Drohne mit Display für 14€. Ja, das wird bestimmt auch ein High-End Produkt sein.
Es gibt auch Lötkolben mit Dampfabsaugung. Oh, sowas wäre cool. Aber ich muss sagen, was so der Rauch und den Dampf beim Löten angeht, ich mache das mittlerweile absolut Noob-Style. Ich mache einfach das Fenster auf und ich habe einen USB-Ventilator daneben stehen.
Kann ich anschließend an die Steckdosenleiste und ich puste einfach oder besser gesagt, ich ziehe das mit dem USB-Ventilator ab Richtung Fenster. Fertig. Mehr mache ich gerade nicht. Zum Absaugen beim Löten.
Ich puste das einfach aus dem Gesicht. Habe ich früher auch immer gemacht, dann saß ich da, habe quasi Luft geholt, mal was gelötet und quasi wenn ich abgesetzt habe, habe ich da gemacht und habe das ganze Lötzeug wieder, die ganzen Dämpfe weggepustet.
Mittlerweile habe ich einen USB-Ventilator daneben stehen. Ich habe ja noch so eine KoGeek Steckdosenleiste, auch geflasht, custom firmware, haben wir uns ja mal im Stream angeguckt. Die hat ja vier normale Stecker und vier USB-Stecker.
Da habe ich den Lötkolben drin und vorne kommt der USB-Ventilator ran und gut ist. Das einzige, was ich sonst noch zum Löten habe, ist halt die Lötstation, eine Silikonunterlage und eine Lupe, falls man eine braucht. So eine Lupe mit Licht drum herum. Sonst habe ich nichts. Kann ich alles Mögliche mit löten, was ich bisher so löten musste.
Das einzige, wo es wirklich eklig wird, ist wenn man so kleine SMD-Teile hat. Ich habe noch nie ein komplettes Board SMD gelötet, muss ich sagen. Ich habe nur mal auf fertigen Boards was abgelötet oder mal was dran gemacht wieder. Aber das ist ohne Lupe und mit großer Spitze eklig.
Du brauchst aber auch eine Heißluft. Hab ich. Hab ich. Ich habe keine Heißluftstation, ich habe so eine Heißluftpistole, aber es kommt auch gleich heraus, wo du vorne so einen Aufsatz machen kannst, dass es dann kleiner wird.
Da hatte ich mir mal das Ding hier gekauft. So ein Teil. Ich glaube die da mit so einem Aufsatz für kleine Sachen drinne. Die ist auch ziemlich gut.
Kennst du den TS100? Ja, das ist der USB-Load-Kolben. Der USB-Load-Kolben mit Custom-Firmware.
Letztens habe ich was ganz Abenteuerliches mit dem Heißluftfön, Heißluftgebläse, Pistole, wie auch immer gemacht. Und zwar hatte ich hier einen Raspberry Pi Automation Head.
Den kleinen Automation Head. Den da, genau. Und ich habe die Pins falsch rum angelötet. Ich habe die Pins nach oben angelötet, obwohl ich sie hätte nach unten anlöten müssen.
Das war natürlich prinzipiell cool, weil ich kleiner auf den Raspberry Pi draufstecken kann. Das Problem ist nur, die Anschlüsse sind dann spiegelverkehrt und es geht nicht.
Big Brain Time. Und ich hatte glücklicherweise hatte ich auch einen Raspberry Pi Zero mit auch falsch rum angelöteten Pins. Das heißt, die hätten wunderbar zusammengepasst. Weil beides falsch rum passt wieder zusammen.
Das Problem war nur, dass ich gerade diesen Raspberry Pi Zero bei mir quasi outdoor für die Kamera am Hoftor verbaut habe. Das heißt, ich konnte es nicht verwenden.
So, und was habe ich gemacht? Nachdem ich keinen Bock hatte bzw. den Scheiß nicht abgekriegt habe, weil ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen, wer das nicht gemacht hat, man kriegt den Scheiß nicht mehr ab. Also wenn die Pins erst mal drauf sind, sprich wenn du die Pins hier erst mal angelötet hast da, du kriegst den Scheiß nicht mehr ab.
Einzige Sache, wie du es abkriegst ist halt, wenn du so ein bisschen Kupferdraht hast, der fürs Entlöten, ich glaube, dass das Kupfer ist oder irgendeine Kupfer-Gold-Mischung oder so, frag mich nicht, das hält man dann da drauf und macht heiß und das zieht dann das Lötze ein bisschen weg.
Aber ist ein ganz schönes Gefrickel, bis du den Scheiß wieder raus hast. Und außerdem hatte ich gerade keinen Star, mittlerweile habe ich mir mal was bestellt. Und auch gleich so eine Absaugung, dass man den Kram wegziehen kann, so eine Vakuum-Saugeding.
Machs gut Nicky30. Und es war ganz, ganz abartig. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ok, jetzt machen wir einfach mal Big Brain und ich habe mein Heißluftgebläse, Heißluftfön geholt und habe das ganze Ding heiß gemacht und den Header heiß gemacht und dann auf einen Schlag rausgezogen.
So, hast du Erfahrungen mit Arduino? Mit Arduino selber nicht, aber mit ESP32 und ESP866. Also wenn du was wissen willst, schieß los.
Das Problem da nur war dann, dass, und das, dann wurde es echt schwierig, danach war das Lötzen ja noch drinne und ich musste einen neuen Header reinmachen bzw. einen alten Header umdrehen auf die andere Seite reinmachen.
So, also habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen jetzt absolut Next Level Big Brain und wir heizen das einfach nochmal auf und dann nehmen wir uns eine Zange, weil das kannst du nicht angreifen, das Zeug ist dann mega heiß, dann nimmst du eine Zange und du hast ungefähr so eine halbe Sekunde bis maximal zwei Sekunden Zeit, wo das Lötzen noch flüssig ist, wenn du den Fön weglegst.
Und habe ich dann heiß gemacht und habe dann quasi innerhalb von zwei Sekunden den Header auf die andere Seite gesetzt.
Natürlich blöd wie das gelaufen ist, habe ich nicht richtig getroffen und dann hing er dann da halb drinne. An der einen Seite drinne und an der anderen Seite nicht richtig drinne.
So, und dann habe ich gedacht, machste einfach nochmal warm, weil im Lötkolben kriegste das ja nicht hin, da müsstest du den Lötkolben quasi hier ganz schnell drüber schleifen, sodass es alles funktioniert nicht.
Und dann habe ich nochmal heiß gemacht und das Problem ist, ich habe es beim ersten Mal schon gesehen, dass das Board sich anfängt zu biegen, wenn es zu heiß wird.
Also habe ich halt nicht so sehr auf das Board geföhnt, sondern habe hier oben mehr auf die Pins geföhnt mit dem Heißluft. Das Heißluftding ist irgendwie 500 Grad warm oder so.
So, und mit dem neuen Header hätte ich auch kein Problem gehabt. So, und das gleiche Problem gehabt. So, und wisst ihr was dann passiert ist?
Dann habe ich nicht auf das Board geföhnt, sondern auf den Header und dann habe ich das ganze Plastik verschmolzen vom Header.
Dann war der Header richtig drinne, aber ich konnte nichts reinstecken, weil das Plastik kaputt war.
Exzellent!
Also das ganze Plastik war zusammengeschmolzen.
Pin Header.
Ja, so sieht das Kram ja von oben aus.
So sieht das Kram ja von oben aus und die ganzen Löcher waren zusammengeschmolzen.
Also, danach hin. Heißluft unten abgeföhnt wieder. Header rausgenommen.
Neun Header geholt.
Diesmal das Ding richtig hingelegt, fixiert, nochmal heiß gemacht und es wirklich geschafft, auf einem Rutsch, nachdem ich alle Lötschstellen quasi mit dem Heißluftgerät kurz heiß gepustet habe, anzunehmen.
Alles in einem Rutsch reinzustecken und es hat funktioniert. Und dann hebe ich das Board hoch. Also es hat wunderbar funktioniert, alles dran, wunderbar, wunderbar.
Dann hebe ich das Board hoch und ich habe das Relay abgelötet, weil es zu heiß geworden ist.
Und ich habe das Relay abgelötet, weil es zu heiß geworden ist. Da lag dann das Relay einfach auf dem Tisch.
Ne, ne, nicht wieder falsch rum. Dann habe ich das Relay mit dem Lötkollen wieder angelötet. Das Board sah danach aus, ey. Wie aus der China-Produktion, ne?
Überall teilweise Farbe ab, teilweise Lötschen, Spritzer irgendwo drauf. Das Board war 30 Grad gebogen, der Header war nicht richtig drinnen, das Relay war nicht mehr richtig drauf, aber, ihr werdet lachen, der Scheiß hat funktioniert.
Der Kram hat funktioniert danach.
Komplett. Der Analogsensor, der ADC hat funktioniert, der, ähm, das Relay hat funktioniert, alles.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass der Kram noch funktioniert. Spätestens seitdem ich da irgendwelche Teile aus Versehen abgelötet habe.
Tja.
Oh, 22.09 Leute, ich muss ins Bett.
Bei eurem Homeoffice. Ich würde sagen, wir machen morgen an der Stelle weiter, weil wir haben ja sehr viel heute eingekauft.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen morgen an der Stelle weiter, weil wir haben ja sehr viel heute eingekauft. Lötest du ohne Flussmittel? Ja. Also ohne, ich hab mir so nen, ich hab so nen, so ne Packung aus, ähm, weiß gar nicht wie das genau heißt, das ist so Flux, ähm, mit, mit Lötschen drinnen.
Das kann man quasi auf die Teile, an die Stellen streichen, wo man was haben will. Dann legt man das drauf und dann pustet man drauf und dann lötet sich das selber an.
Hab ich aber noch nie ausprobiert.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist Löt, das ist so Löt, wie heißt denn das, Flux? Das ist so so Löt, Löt, Harz, Kram und da drin sind kleine Kügelchen Lötzinn. Lötpaste, genau, genau, genau. Äh, ich seh hier, der Lumix kennt sich aus. Und das ist sehr praktisch, hab ich gehört.
Hab ich aber noch nie ausprobiert. Ähm, das ist, das ist so Fließmittel mit, ähm, mit kleinen Kügelchen Lötzinn drinnen und da streicht man, da streicht man auf das Board und puste dann mit nem Heißluft, Föhn, Heißluftgebläse drauf und dann lötet sich das selber an.
Das ist, das ist so Fließmittel mit, ähm, mit kleinen Kügelchen Lötzinn drinnen und da streicht man, da streicht man auf das Board und puste dann mit nem Heißluft, Föhn, Heißluftgebläse drauf und dann lötet sich die Teile am besten Fall selber fest.
Das ist cool. Ähm, ich guck jetzt mal grad noch die letzten Fragen an. Storytime mit Max, ja. Pepega Wubblos, richtig Pepega, Massive Pepega. Davon hatte ich tatsächlich keinen Zehnerpack. Hätte ich, hätte ich mal machen sollen, ja.
Microsoft Header, easy, easy, easy. Das ist nicht Microsoft Header, das ist Microsoft Sam. Hast du Erfahrungen mit Arduino? Ja, wie gesagt, gab's da noch ne Follow-Up-Frage? Wer hat das gefragt?
Wer hat das gefragt? Fisch, Fisch994. Hat der Fisch, hat der Fisch noch was anderes gefragt danach? Oder hab ichs nur übersehen? Der Fisch, der Fisch hat nix mal gefragt. Dann, ja, dann kann ich auch nix machen.
Game Electro, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön, hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Huge Prime Sub. Massive. High IQ Sub.
Was hältst du vom TS100? Hab ich nicht. Ich find die Idee aber cool. Mit nem USB-Lötkolben. Ich hab mir so ganz ganz billigen USB-Lötkolben mir mal gekauft, weil ich unbedingt nen USB-Lötkolben haben wollte.
Ähm, die Idee find ich cool, dass man nen USB-Lötkolben hat mit Custom-Firmware. Oder beziehungsweise mit Flashbarer-Firmware. Eigentlich nice.
Dein Memeball kannst du eigentlich an andere Twitch-Streamer verkaufen. Oh, excellent Idee. Da müsste ichs vielleicht mal fertig machen.
Ich glaube wirklich, wenn man das gut machen würde, könnte man damit potentiell sogar ein paar Euro verdienen. Aber hab ich eigentlich auch nicht vor.
Oh, was ist jetzt los? Ah ne, die Musik ist einfach ausgegangen. Kommt da genau genug Strom aus dem USB-Pod, ja?
Was soll die Firma im Lötkolben machen? Ja, frag mich doch nicht so Sachen. Ich hab das nicht ausprobiert.
Ab ins Bett ist 22 Uhr. Excellent. Hast recht, ja. Ich wollt ja eigentlich aufgehen.
Schau dir mal das hier an. Kann ich das wirklich aufmachen, ja? Ohne dass ich jetzt hier Monka-Tost werde?
Huge Photoshop-Skills.
Noch nicht mal das Wasser ist echt.
Großes Ding.
Wie viele Accounts hast du bei AliExpress? Einen? So Leute, aber ich muss jetzt wirklich, ich muss jetzt wirklich auf.
Hast du eigentlich für jedes Meme im Tool eine Quelle? Oh nein. Ich hab doch mein eigenes, ich hab doch mein eigenes, ein Board, Meme-Board-Einplendungs-Ding hier.
Okay Leute, macht's gut. Wir sehen uns vielleicht morgen. Vielleicht klappt das jetzt ja wirklich mal mit regelmäßigem Stream so.
Wir werden morgen eigentlich noch ein Video machen, wo ich euch noch ein Video machen kann, wo ich euch noch ein Video machen kann.
Wir werden morgen einfach genau an der gleichen Stelle mit China-Einkaufen weitermachen, weil heute hat das ja mit China-Einkaufen wahnsinnig gut funktioniert.
Wir haben ja nichts eingekauft von dem, was ich einkaufen wollte. Also Leute, wir sehen uns morgen. Macht's gut, schlaft gut. Bis denn, see you.